- Welcome everyone.
My name is Jeremy Schwartz.
I'm an Associate Professor of Medicine
at the Yale School of Medicine
and of Epidemiology at the
Yale School of Public Health.
I'm also the lead of the
Faculty Network Development
of Faculty Network Development
at the Yale Institute for Global Health.
I'm delighted to welcome you
to today's conversation series
event with Winnie Byanyima
the Executive Director of UNAIDS.
I'm coming to you today from Uganda,
where I'm currently living,
and where I've been engaged
as a clinician, educator
and researcher for nearly 20 years.
So the fact that Winnie
Byanyima, our guest is a Ugandan,
makes this even more special for me.
In addition to YIGH,
today's event is co-sponsored
by the Walker Fund
at the MacMillan Center
and the Center for
Interdisciplinary Research
on HIV and AIDS at Yale.
It's a pleasure to be with
all of you here today.
Many of the drivers of gender
inequality in the HIV epidemic
are the same as those driving inequality
in the COVID-19 pandemic.
For example, as we've seen
during the COVID-19 pandemic,
women and girls are at heightened
risk of domestic violence
and inadequate access
to essential healthcare,
including HIV prevention and sexual
and reproductive health services.
To better prepare for the future,
during today's conversation,
we will discuss the imperative
to address the underlying social factors,
including gender inequality
that exacerbate these pandemics.
These issues of equity
and social determinants
and their impact on health
at home and around the world
are important for Yale
faculty and students.
The faculty network program
at the Yale Institute for Global Health
is proud to support
almost a dozen networks
that address some of
the greatest challenges
in global health.
You're welcome to learn
more about our program
on the YIGH website.
In tandem with this event today
and in close collaboration with CIRA,
the Center for Interdisciplinary
Research on AIDS at Yale,
we launch the newest addition
to our faculty network program
known as the Yale Global
HIV/AIDS Research Network
or GARNER for short.
This new network will aim
to bring together Yale
faculty and other partners
to support global
interdisciplinary research
on the implementation of HIV prevention
and treatment services
that reduce disparities
and work toward ending the HIV epidemic.
To introduce Winnie Byanyima
and to moderate today's conversation,
I'll now turn this over to my
colleague, mentor and friend,
and one of the leads of
GARNER, Dr. Luke Davis.
- Thank you very much, Jeremy.
Hello everyone.
My name is Luke Davis and
I'm Associate Professor
of Epidemiology and of Medicine at Yale.
I'm also the faculty lead
of the International Research Program,
the Center for Research on AIDS at Yale.
And I'm a clinician and researcher
who's been working in
Uganda for about 17 years
as part of a collaborations
at Makerere University on TB and HIV.
On December 1st, we will
commemorate World AIDS Day,
a day when we'll reflect
and renew our commitment
to ending the HIV epidemic.
Four decades into the HIV response,
inequality still persists
for the most basic services
like testing, treatment and condoms,
and even more so for new technologies.
Young women in Africa remain
disproportionately affected by HIV,
while coverage of dedicated programs
for them remains too low.
We see similar issues in
the response to COVID-19.
The theme for World AIDS
Day this year is equalize,
where we will recognize the inequalities
which perpetuate the AIDS pandemic
and make sure that they
are not inevitable.
This year, World AIDS Day
will be a call to action,
a push for all of us to work
for the proven programs and strategies
that are needed to address
inequalities and help end AIDS.
With that in mind, it's
my distinct pleasure
to introduce today's distinguished
guest, Winnie Byanyima,
the Executive Director of UNAIDS,
a passionate and longstanding champion
of social justice and gender equality.
Winnie leads UN's efforts to
end the AIDS epidemic by 2030.
She believes that
healthcare is a human right
and was an early champion
of a people's vaccine
against the coronavirus that is available
and free of charge to everyone everywhere.
Before joining UNAIDS, she served
as the Executive Director
of Oxfam International,
empowering people to create a future
that is secure, just
and free from poverty.
Winnie was elected for three terms
and served 11 years in the parliament
of her home country, Uganda.
Winnie, also led the establishment
of the African Union
Commission's Directorate
of Gender and Development,
and also served as Director
of Gender and Development
at the UN Development Program.
She founded the Forum
for Women in Democracy,
an influential Ugandan
non-governmental organization,
and it's been deeply
involved in building global
and African coalitions
on social justice issues.
She's a passion advocate
and we're incredibly honored
to have her here with us today.
Welcome, Winnie.
- Professor Luke Davis
and Professor Schwartz,
thank you for inviting me to
be part of this discussion.
And you have to tell me,
because I'm not smart enough to know
how you managed to be
working in the sunshine
by Lake Victoria, and I'm sitting here
in dump and cold, Geneva.
Gotta show me how you do that.
Thank you very much for having me,
and I'm looking forward to an exchange
with young people at Yale, is a privilege.
How do you want this to go?
- Well, thanks Winnie.
It's wonderful to have you with us.
The theme of World AIDS Day
today of 2022 is equalized.
And I wanted to start just by asking you,
because you have been a
champion for this topic,
why is equality so critical to
ending the HIV/AIDS epidemic?
And maybe more broadly, what
do you think is required
to achieve equality?
- Thank you for that question.
I keep saying that
HIV/AIDS is an injustice
because today we have tools for prevention
and we have tools for testing
and tools for treatment.
We don't have a vaccine
and we don't have a cure.
But what we have in between
these tools that we have
of every type that will work for children,
will work for adults,
will work for gay people,
for all groups of people
that these tools are there.
But yet, last year we had
1.5 million new infections,
most of them in Africa,
and we had 650,000 people
who died of AIDS related illnesses.
So in spite of what we
have, what science provides,
we still have people nearly
infected, people dying.
And when you peel that and
see who is being infected,
who is dying, that's when you really see
inequalities driving HIV/AIDS.
As indeed they drive other
pandemics, as we saw in COVID,
as you rightly put it.
Take Africa...
And first inequalities of every kind.
Gender inequalities, income inequalities,
racial inequalities.
And often where they intersect
is where you have the
highest vulnerability.
So I can give you some examples in Africa.
In sub-Saharan Africa,
adolescent girls and young
women are three times
as likely to acquire HIV as
adolescent boys and young men.
That's just looking at a
gender inequality there.
You also find between,
in the cohort of 15 and 19 years of age,
teenagers that six out of
seven newly infected teenagers
are girls.
One is a boy, six are girls.
It tells you the higher
vulnerability of girls.
And why is that?
It's driven by gender inequalities.
Unequal opportunity to education,
unequal opportunity to sexual information,
unequal access to services
and sexual violence,
which is actually a result
of a gender inequality.
Sexual violence is an
indicator of gender inequality.
So you find that inequalities are driving
the higher vulnerability
of adolescent girls and young women.
4,200 adolescent girls young women
are infected every...
You might say every year.
No.
Every month?
Every week, 4,200, it's a crisis.
So then still talking about inequalities,
take the United States where you are,
where many of the students are.
Black people are eight and a half times
more likely to be diagnosed
with HIV than white people.
That's just taking a racial difference.
But if you take it further,
you'll find that black gay men
in the United States
have a one in two risk
of contracting HIV across
their lifetime, one in two.
Black gay men in the
richest country on earth.
This is a higher lifetime risk
than the average in Uganda,
low income country where I come from.
And almost as high as the
risk in hotspot regions
like South Africa and Zimbabwe.
Think about it.
When two access of
inequality come together,
sexual orientation and race,
you see the vulnerability,
the risk rising much higher.
So inequalities, I could
give you more examples.
In Canada, indigenous
people are several times
more vulnerable than the
rest of the population
and so on and so on.
So we see...
And I have many good examples, but time.
So we see that inequalities,
denial of opportunities,
denial of services,
unequal access to services,
discrimination and stigma,
which result in inequality of opportunity
and inequality and access
to services or drive HIV.
Close them, reduce them
and then you see vulnerability
and risk dropping very much.
I'll give you one last example.
In Malaysia where there's
a concentrated epidemic
where same sex relations are criminalized,
men who have sex with men are 72 times,
72 times, more likely
to be living with HIV
then the general population.
Not 72 times, 72% more
likely to be living with HIV
than the whole population.
Now you compare that with Thailand,
another concentrated epidemic
where same sex relations
are not criminalized.
Men who have sex with men are nearly 12%
more likely to be living with HIV.
72, 12.
So just removing the law
that hunts down gay men
reduces their vulnerability.
So that is why we say equalize, equalize.
'Cause when you equalize,
when you close the gaps,
you reduce the risk for others.
And it also goes for deaths.
because deaths are a result
of not staying on treatment.
And when you have full access to treatment
and you have a equal right to treatment,
then again the risk of dying is less.
So close the gaps,
close the gaps by removing
those laws that discriminate,
that drive stigma, equalize
opportunities of education,
of information, of access to healthcare,
of social protection.
And then you will reduce the
risk and also the deaths.
A long answer.
- Thank you, Winnie.
We know that at this time of year
we're thinking about the
global HIV/AIDS epidemic,
but of course it's many
different epidemics
affecting many different people.
And I think you've highlighted
some of the unique barriers to delivery
of some of the gains of science
that have been great in
the field of HIV/AIDS,
but also gains in giving access to people.
We need to go further in giving
equitable access to everyone
to these life saving interventions.
I guess as you talk
about some of the drivers
some of the drivers are
similar around the world.
Stigma may vary based on the population,
but we know stigma and discrimination,
whether it's adolescent
girls and young women
as you were talking
about, or black gay men
these are important factors.
I guess another factor that I'd love
to hear you talk a little bit about
are economic inequalities.
You mentioned that in your
first set of comments,
and I think we're all familiar
that we're facing a growing
worldwide economic crisis,
some related to the recent COVID pandemic
and also to other factors,
war in Ukraine, et cetera.
And this has had major
effects on societies
around the world in 2022,
I know that you often write
and speak about how such economic factors
whether we're talking about inflation
or more specific issues like
global vaccine distribution,
how these can drive health
inequities and inequalities.
And I'm just curious, given
that you've been very outspoken
and a strong advocate,
how do your perspectives
on economic justice influence your work
in your role at UNAIDS?
- Luke, I'm glad you raised that question
and I think here at UNAIDS,
our approach to fighting HIV/AIDS
has been leaning very heavily
on the biomedical side,
less on looking at the
social determinants,
the structural barriers
that need to be removed.
So we do not even have
sufficient data that we would use
to make this linkage
of economic inequality
and vulnerability to HIV.
But slowly we are pulling it together.
For example, we know that
overall people in urban areas
have significantly higher
HIV prevalence than rural,
but that the urban poor
have the highest prevalence
of all in country after
country, urban poor.
We also know that in Namibia,
while 8% of richer people,
non poor, if you could say so
in cities are living with HIV.
15% of the urban poor
have HIV, at last measure.
So we see a correlation
between income inequality
as well as all the social
factors that come with poverty
and higher vulnerability.
But now if you also look
at who gets services,
you see them skewed
towards richer populations,
towards urban populations
and less to rural poor.
That is also, you see that in
terms of access to services,
who is falling out of
treatment, for example.
So in terms of economic injustices,
we see this also at the national level.
At the national level, you see countries
that have the highest burden,
highest burden of HIV
struggling to pay debt.
And that debt keeps increasing
and taking more and more
out of the total budget
and squeezing out expenditures on health,
expenditures on education.
Let me tell you what really
shocked me most was that
in the midst of the
crisis, the COVID crisis,
when countries that are
rich were powering trillion,
17 trillion was put into
the recovery cushioning,
the economy of rich countries.
That's not talking about the money
put in to buying the COVID vaccine.
Developing countries, middle
income and low income,
where continuing to make debt repayments
that were four times, several times,
sometimes four times more
than their health budgets,
imagine that.
In a time of illness where
there was a killer disease
plus other diseases like HIV,
developing countries spent
27.5 of their total budget,
these are the poor countries
on debt repayments alone,
about a third on debt repayments.
That as I said, four times
more than the health spent,
two times more than the education spent
and 12 times more than social
prediction expenditure.
This is an injustice.
In times of crisis even
you are at a family level
when you are in a mega crisis,
you go to the bank and
you reschedule your debt,
you're given a breathing
space so that you recover
and then you can pay.
But this was not possible.
So we saw at the same time...
By the way, we calculated that every day
the rich 20 countries
who are sitting right now
receive a 136 million per
day in debt repayments
from poor countries who are struggling
just to keep services
going in the health sector.
So this is an injustice.
We do not have a global mechanism,
international financial mechanism
for cushioning countries in
times of crisis like pandemics.
The IMF was created after
the second World War
for the purpose of cushioning countries
from economic and other shocks.
But look,
when COVID hit and entire health sectors
were stretched completely,
healthcare systems,
they came together at the
IMF, they created new money,
which they call special drawing rights,
but they distributed it
according to the formula
that exists, which is that
the bigger shareholders
get the bigger share.
So they allocated the new
money to the rich ones
who didn't need it.
It was a scandal.
There was a lot of
pressure from many of us
saying this is not meaningful.
The ones who need most
this system of cushioning
isn't cushioning them.
They came back now and said, okay
we shall take our new money
and we will loan it to you
at a concessionary rate.
Imagine SDLs were
created to give you money
without incurring debt,
but now they are offering them
to the low income countries with a debt.
So there isn't a system to
cushion countries from pandemics,
and that's really an injustice.
Healthcare should not be something
that waits for other
deals to, this is life.
The second example is
about access to medicines.
I don't have to repeat the story
of what happened during COVID,
where a handful of companies,
a handful were allowed to decide
how much vaccine is produced,
at what price it is
sold and who can buy it.
Poor countries pulled
their money together,
Africa tried to pull money together.
They were told stand in
the back of the queue
where richer countries took everything,
stocked up for themselves,
hoarded and even expired,
vaccines expired and this happened
because it is allowed happen
because the trade rules are now medicines,
life saving health commodities to be sold
the way you can sell a luxury item,
like a fancy pen I'm holding here.
How can that be?
But it's allowed.
We went to the trips, the WTO body
that regulates intellectual
property to ask
that there is a waiver
that allows all countries
to take that technology and
produce it for themselves.
No, it was not allowed and who refused?
A handful of countries whose companies
were reaping the billions.
So we saw Pfizer make 137 billion
in one year alone of profit
from a drug that had been produced
with the help of public resources
from you American taxpayers
and German taxpayers.
And we did an opinion poll.
Ordinary Americans, Germans,
British people were saying,
no profit should be
made from this vaccines
before the COVID pandemic is over.
But the companies held the monopoly.
So we argue against these trade rules
that treat life saving treatments
the same way they treat luxury
items like a Gucci handbag.
We argue against that, it's an injustice.
So these are the things
that are driving ill-health globally.
We need to change the
global rules of trade.
We need also to deal with
the rules of taxation.
These companies are not paying
their fair share of taxes.
They are able to hide
through many tax loopholes,
to channel their profits
from one country to another,
put it in tax savings
where it's not taxed.
And that denies small
countries, poor countries,
the resources they need to pay
for the health of their people.
We've calculated the
billions that are transferred
to tax havens every year that
developing countries lose.
It's phenomenal.
It is several times over the
little aid that is received.
So sometimes people make
health an issue of aid.
Yes, I'm sitting here
using an aid check from rich countries,
but it shouldn't be like that
if we corrected the tax injustices
in the global corporate tax system.
So you see that global rules
enable or drive inequalities,
which result in ill health
of some, death of some
and huge mega profits for
a handful, for few people.
So that is what we mean
about the economic injustices
in the global system, but
also at the national level.
We have our own governance
that are not prioritizing
everybody's health.
In much of Africa, probably
more than 33 countries,
health is paid for by the poorest people,
user fees are collected for people to get,
and many times people die of malaria,
babies die of diarrhea because a mother
or a father can't afford
this small user fee charge.
And why is that?
You see money being channeled
through to other sectors,
to large public administrations
that you don't need,
to defense expenditures,
to all kinds of expenditures
that are less important
than people's lives,
so that's an injustice.
So we see how economies,
the way they are managed,
the rules in the trade system,
in the taxation system,
the rules in technology,
how technology is produced,
intellectual property rules
all these work against justice
and drive pandemics such as HIV.
I should stop there.
- Thank you Winnie for highlighting...
I think the audience is chiming in
and appreciating your examples,
helping us understand sort
of this issue of equality
and I think particularly
the economic examples
that the structural factors
that are baked into our system
at the macroeconomic level.
You talked about some of
the microeconomic challenges
that individuals face.
And it's very, I think,
helpful to know what the barriers are.
And you've also provided some solutions.
This is a conversation
with Winnie Byanyima
and I encourage those in the audience
to add your questions into the chat.
We will get to a point in a few minutes
where we'll be taking those.
But I do have a few more questions
that I would love to ask.
And one of the factors--
- I know you Luke
I just want to give you one more example
because this is close to home.
- Yes please.
- Pharmaceutical companies in
the United States of America
paid more than a hundred,
more than a hundred million
dollars in lobbying fees,
lobbying your Congress and Senate.
Why?
It is not because they
are paying legislators
to find a cure for malaria.
No, it is so that they can keep
the price of medicines high.
This is part of the problem.
The corporate grid and the
rules I was talking about
in the national systems that
allow certain things to happen,
lobbying by pharmaceutical companies
to keep prices high, to keep taxes low,
hurts ordinary citizens,
hurts not only ordinary
citizens in the United States,
but all over the world
because they are lobbying
about prices of goods
that they're going to sell
also to other countries.
So these are rules that have to change
if people have to have a chance
to access medicine that is
cheap, that is affordable.
Sorry, I wanted to give
that example of lobbying
as a rule that hurts the health of people.
- Enormous amount of money directed
to something that is
working against the efforts
that all of us are focused on.
I'm curious the numbers of people
displaced by war and economic
crisis and natural disasters
is a topic that of special interest
to a number of researchers here at Yale
and clinicians as well and these numbers
have kinda climbed over the last decade.
We know that women and girls comprise
more than half of refugee and
displaced people worldwide
and they're also in that
context at a greater risk
of gender based violence.
And I'm just curious,
given your perspective,
I know you've worked in the area
of humanitarian crisis
in your previous roles
and understand it well.
What can the global health community do
to support displaced
populations, refugee populations,
populations living in humanitarian crises
that are increasing around the world
so that we can optimize
the HIV/AIDS response
in these sort of emergency type settings?
- Crisis are increasing,
these numbers of displaced are increasing
because of the complexity of issues
of war, climate crisis, poverty.
So people on the move are increasing
and those who are displaced
are also increasing.
We have to find ways to get
health services to reach them.
And the surest way we know from experience
of working on HIV/AIDS
is to support communities
to deliver services for themselves.
We found this to work, say in Ukraine.
Ukraine is a country
that has the second highest burden
of HIV/AIDS in Eastern Europe,
Eastern Europe and
Central Asia, that region.
It's second into Russia
in terms of numbers
of people living with HIV.
Many are people who inject drugs
or men who have sex with men.
But Ukraine, unlike Russia
and many of the other
countries of Eastern Europe
had a system of delivering services
for HIV prevention and treatment
that were driven by communities,
Ukrainian communities to lead services.
So you would have gay communities
serve delivering services to gay people.
You have people who inject drugs,
trained to serve people who inject drugs.
And you have geographical
communities serving themselves.
Now, when the war broke out,
it was possible for many of us
who were in global health
to follow these communities
and continue to support them
because they were moving with their people
and they knew their people
and they could find them.
And most importantly, for
a person living with HIV
who say crosses from Ukraine to Moldova
or from one part of Ukraine to another,
the first is it...
This is not the first thing you want to do
to identify yourself
as, I'm living with HIV.
No, it's your secret, you fear stigma.
But when you are fling with your community
and your community leaders
who run the service
are looking for you,
have your cell number,
they'll find you
and you'll be able to
get on your treatment.
So we found that it was quick
for us in a couple of months.
First they were cut cutoff from services,
but in a few months they
were back on services
because of communities leading.
So for me, the biggest
solution is of course
to empower communities to lead services,
they have the resilience to
adapt when things go bad.
But secondly of course is
put the resources down,
to put down the resources that are needed
to reach people in trouble.
This humanitarian spirit is so important
and I think that this is
how our humanity is tested
to be there to save lives.
And the last one is to
solve the root causes,
the conflicts, the climate crisis.
Stop roasting our planet.
We've got to stop the displacement.
Back to you.
- Thank you, Winnie,
I really appreciate your highlighting
the power of pure lead
interventions in so many ways.
I think there's a number of examples
in our HIV/AIDS community here at Yale,
specifically with the respect
to the war in Ukraine,
responding to the needs
of people who inject drugs
and their need for opiate agonist therapy,
supporting people in HIV care.
And then just responding more broadly.
Many in the Ukrainian
and Russian communities
here have responded.
And I know there's other examples,
we've seen it in Uganda as well.
I wanted to ask you a bit about
given the audience that we have here
and I think the forward
looking view of World AIDS Day,
what are your comments
about how we might educate
and train the next generation of students,
researchers, providers,
advocates and community members,
kind of highlighting
what you had said there
about peer interventions.
How can we harness this group
and help them contribute best
to meaningfully addressing inequalities
as we're focusing on today
and improving the global
HIV/AIDS response?
- That's a very hard one
'cause I'm not a professor,
I don't know how to teach.
But let me think about young people.
I think that first of all,
young people are today not getting
as much information about
HIV/AIDS as an older generation.
And secondly, young people,
particularly in Africa,
but I also see it in other continents,
are not getting sexuality education,
which is critical for life.
Young people are going through school
without knowing about their
bodies, especially girls,
and knowing about how
to live a healthy life
and how to handle their sexuality
as they become teenagers.
Young boys grow up with
toxic masculinities.
They understand their
gender in a violent way
and do not have a healthy,
peaceful masculinity.
So there's a need for sexuality
education for boys and girls
in all our schools so that boys grow up
with a healthy notion of masculinity
and also a positive attitude
towards health seeking.
And girls also need to be
empowered about their bodies
and to know how to own their body
and make choices for themselves.
These things aren't happening
and lives are being lost of young people.
In terms of, at a higher level,
I think that we need the
space, the academic freedom
to use it to discuss difficult
issues like human rights,
LGBTQ rights.
In a country where LGBTQ
people are criminalized,
you want to have a debate at
a university like Makerere,
where maybe you are,
there should be the freedom
for young people to debate these issues
because it is from intellectual
centers like universities
that we can challenge
stigma and discrimination.
I think education on human rights,
on women's rights and using the space,
the academic space to
vocalize, to debate to...
I mean, why can't there be a pride
much at Makerere, if it
can't happen outside,
within the gates of the
university, why can't it happen?
So we really need to
challenge young people
about human rights and women's rights.
I see young people and I get mad,
young people in my country, young men
who are little patriarchs
in the making who they already are.
They've got an attitude about
being superior to women.
Is the education coming from
tradition, religion and so on?
We have to challenge it,
this is a equal world.
So I see the importance
of teaching human rights
to all students, science
students, art students,
and women's rights and debating,
this is what I can say about health,
because health is
ultimately a human right.
It is not just something to trade
and to give away to reach people.
It's a human right and we must center it
around human rights and
focus on it as a human right.
- Thank you for those in inspiring words.
We wanna now shift in our
last 20 or minutes so together
to open up the questions
to some audience members.
And I'll start with one
from Edward Kabagande
who is asking about
cardiovascular diseases.
As we all know, these are
emerging as comorbidities
in HIV/AIDS patients as we've
been able to enable patients
to live longer with HIV/AIDS.
And the question is,
are there coordinated cardiovascular
disease control efforts
in especially thinking about
low and middle income countries
for preventing cardiovascular
disease in HIV populations?
I think specifically Edward
Edmund is interested in
high blood pressure and stroke.
- What is the question?
- Are there coordinated
cardiovascular disease
control efforts that are happening
to prevent cardiovascular
disease in HIV populations?
I know there are some activities
that are going on among
faculty members here at Yale,
but more broadly, what is your perspective
on integrating care for chronic diseases,
especially cardiovascular diseases
in people living with HIV?
- I think as the years go,
and we are now 40 years
since HIV was first isolated,
and as treatments improve and people live
longer and longer lives with HIV,
the issues of comorbidities
have become very important
that people living with HIV
and how other diseases affect them,
including high blood pressure and others.
This is becoming more and more
important in understanding.
Of course for us as a response,
a global response on HIV/AIDS,
the big ones that we pay
attention to are TB and HIV
cause it is a strong correlation.
The most AIDS related
deaths are deaths from TB.
And then now increasingly
we see that mental health
is so important.
For many, many people
who live on treatment
for a very long time it
affects their mental health.
And this is something we
have not worked on for long.
About high blood pressure,
I think that is probably
lower down the list of priorities
that we work on in the
global HIV response.
But it's probably an important area
and I have not read much about it.
- Well thanks for your thoughts there.
I'd also also to talk a little bit about,
we highlighted and you highlighted earlier
this issue of adolescent
girls and young women,
but women more generally
being much more vulnerable
to the effects of HIV.
And one of the questioners is asking,
just given this disproportionate impact,
could you comment a
little bit on coordinated
and concentrated efforts
to tailor treatments
specifically to women?
One example is given is
sort of breaking the cycle
of maternal to child transmission,
but I know there's many other
women specific examples,
it'd be interesting to
hear your perspective on.
- That takes me back also
to the social determinants.
Do you know that it is a shame
that children are left behind
in the HIV response.
That globally 75% of all
people living with HIV,
are on treatment,
but the number for children is just 50%.
50%.
So half the children living with HIV today
are not on treatment, they are dying.
And we still have countries,
many countries even in spite
of the treatment that is there,
that still have mothers
transmitting HIV to their babies.
And you have to ask yourself why.
Goes back to inequalities.
When you look at those countries
that have high rates of
mother to child transmission,
they're the same countries
or those countries have a high...
Or let me put it this with yeah,
high numbers of teenage mothers.
Teenage mothers.
You find that the biggest
number of the mothers
who have transmitted HIV to their babies
are actually children themselves.
They are girls who've given birth.
They are 16, they're 17,
they're 18, and this is...
And they're poor and this is
the reason why they transmit.
First as you know, if
you are living in Africa,
if a girl gets pregnant,
perhaps seven out of 10 chances are that
she will leave home.
She will go stay with an aunt.
She'll go stay with her sister,
she'll go to hide at her boyfriends.
She's shunned by the
family and the community.
That movement alone means
that she moves away from
where she has services, where
she knows, she's in hiding.
Those are factors that lead
to not accessing services.
'Cause if she went for antenatal,
she would quickly tested
and put on treatment
and she wouldn't transmit.
So we have to solve many issues,
not enough to put medicine in the clinics,
ARVs in the clinics.
We have to solve those
issues of teenage mothers.
And when we don't connect
these two, we keep saying,
but why are the numbers coming down?
We have some programs,
I've seen some programs
where they tell a mother to bring,
bring the man who made you pregnant.
They disappear, they don't come back
because the circumstances are that
she dare not even tell
whoever made her pregnant
that she's HIV positive.
So addressing those social factors,
addressing those barriers
that stop young women
from coming forward to save
their babies is important.
And once the baby's born positive,
they also fear the stigma
of taking the child to be put on treatment
because then the child will know
and then her secret will be known.
And I've just come from Jamaica.
I went to a community led service,
I met five users of the service.
Two of them were women who
had been using the center
for 18 years, they'd been
going there for their ARVs.
They laughed, they
joked, they were at home
with the leaders of the
center, the service providers.
When we talked, I asked them,
I said, they had children.
I said, "Do you tell young
women in your community
"to be careful, to save
themselves, to prevent,
"to ask for safe sex?
"Do you tell them?"
They said, "What! We
cannot say the word HIV.
"Nobody in our community knows
that we are HIV positive.
"If we talked about HIV,
"we would be known and
we would be shunned."
Imagine 18 years, their
communities know nothing.
Their friends who know their secret
are those who come to the center.
So imagine this kind of stigma,
what that means for a
child growing with HIV
who is HIV positive.
It's too hard.
So many moms will not tell their child
and will not let them have treatment
and will watch them die.
So we have to address those
issues of stigma, fight stigma,
fight discrimination
before we can have everyone
come forward to get service.
- Winnie, there's a lot of interest
in sort of the effects of COVID-19.
Some people asking about
whether it affects HIV outcomes
and what's the burden of
COVID-19 on people with HIV.
But maybe more broadly,
quite a few questions about how COVID-19
has affected the way we
deliver HIV services.
Whether you're thinking about HIV testing
or even some of the social factors.
Some are highlighting just
the role of domestic violence
kind of during the COVID-19 pandemic.
Maybe the broad question would be then is,
how has COVID-19 changed
the task that you faced
and that we all face to
kind of address HIV/AIDS
going forward the pandemic.
- Let me start with what is
positive, that excites me.
Some things changed for
the better from COVID
in our HIV response.
Some policies, for example,
that we had been advocating
and that we know would help
people to stay on treatment
and be safe and be virally
suppressed finally came to happen
like multi-month dispensing.
We had been telling many governments that,
please allow people who are regular
in coming for their treatment
to get a stock of drugs
for six months or at least
start with three months
so they don't have to come every month.
But many governments fearing
that they are not in good control
of the supply chain wouldn't do it.
So they were still requiring
people to come every month,
sometimes every twice a month.
But when COVID hit and
the public safety measures
required to lock down people,
then they had no choice
but start rolling out
multi-month dispensing.
And then they realized that it works,
that it actually saves them.
Because people were not
coming to the clinic.
Then the second other innovations came in.
You got people, I'm always
proud to tell this story.
In India, people living with
HIV, getting on their bikes,
collecting the ARVs for a group of them
and going around
distributing to each other,
so they would take turns.
These were innovations.
And then using the phone,
finally telemedicine came to health to HIV
because now they were using
the phone to locate people,
to drop off supplies
because people fear stigma.
They tell you where to
drop it, they pick it up,
but it's all on the phone.
So all these innovations came
in the way services are provided
as a result of the public safety measures.
But bad things also happened.
Violations of human rights.
People who are already stigmatized
tend to be targeted, scapegoated
when there's fear and
panicking in society.
So you got gay men
suddenly becoming more
oppressed, more victimized.
You got sex workers being
thrown out of their homes
and being told that they are victors
of the coronavirus.
I came to Uganda to see President Museveni
because there was a group
of about 40 or so gay men
who were found hiding in
a shelter and arrested
and taken to prison for nothing.
And horrible tests were done on them.
So I went to see him and asked
him to have them released.
Then he said to me, I need
to tell you this anecdote.
He said, "But they are in prison
"because they violated COVID
rules or COVID laws here.
"There are not supposed to
be so many in one building."
Can you not...
I said, "But it's a
shelter, Mr. President,
"these are people run
away from their homes."
"They're in a shelter."
And said, "Well, can't you
UNAIDS build many houses?"
What kind of question is that?
I said, "But we don't
build houses for people.
"This is a kind person
who's given them a shelter
"and that's where they stay."
And he said, "Well, we're going to see,
"but this is a breach of our rules,
"we don't want many people crowding.
Then I looked at him, I said,
"Mr. President," he was in
his state house in Entebbe.
I said, Mr. President,
"but down the road there on Buganda Road,
"there's a group of 50 women in one house,
"why haven't you arrested them?"
He said, "What! Who are those?"
I said, "The nuns, they're in a convent."
And he busted out and laughed.
He said, "You go to me."
But it's totally ridiculous
that gay men staying in
a shelter were a risk
but in all these other places,
they were religious communities
nobody was touching them.
So discrimination was rampant.
And we saw the violation of human rights.
We issued a report about
it, drew attention to it.
So those were the...
But in terms of the general
response to HIV/AIDS
some things also hurt
us, were thrown off track
because governments run out of money.
Both the donors were pouring money
into saving their people
and were putting in their economies
to keep them growing or at least stable.
And we are cutting the money,
the little money that goes
to supporting HIV responses
in developing countries.
We fought to keep this money flowing
and we are still fighting.
But we were hurt because many countries
still depend on the
American program, PEPFA
as well as the global fund.
And we were seeing...
But actually I have to say this credit
to the United States government.
In the middle of all that,
they actually increased their contribution
to some of our work, but
some other countries reduced.
We also saw, sadly that the same story
of what had happened with ARVs
when they were first produced
and it took 10 years before
they became available
in the south, because of the price,
because of the monopoly of companies.
We saw it play out again.
And we had tried to say,
let's learn the best lesson.
12 million people died mostly in Africa
while we waited for
the price to come down.
Does it have to happen again?
But no, we didn't learn the lesson.
So again, we saw the same rules
working to hurt a global response.
But now we came back fighting.
We are now fighting for
long acting injectables
Long acting injectables for
prevention are now available.
If you are in New York, you can have it.
You can get a jab and for
two months you are safe.
You can have sex and you will not,
with someone who has HIV,
but you won't contract it.
If you are in London, you can have it.
It's affordable,
but it's not available for a
gay man yet in South Africa
or in Uganda or in Kenya,
the price is still too high
and the countries cannot import it yet.
We are fighting for
this price to come down.
Long acting antiretrovirals
will be a game changer
for young women and girls.
Because young girls and young women are,
most of the time, hiding,
don't want to be known that
either they're having sex
or they're positive and can't control,
can't negotiate safe sex.
But imagine having an injection
that prevents for six
months, or you have the ARV
and you don't have to swallow a tablet,
nobody has to see if you are a girl,
you're not swallowing a tablet,
you're not causing attention to yourself
but you get a jab every six months.
It'll be a game changer,
but it'll be available
first in rich countries,
we'll have to fight to get the price down.
Some people will die before
the price comes down,
but we'll do it, we have to do it.
And you young people must
be part of these campaigns.
And it was the alliance of
gay men in America and Europe
with people in the south
that brought the price
of antiretroviral down
and the leadership of people
like President Mandela.
So it'll take global
alliances to end AIDS,
to bring prices down, to
have access to medicine,
to the best of science,
and to remove these laws and policies
that create barriers for people.
- Winnie, thank you.
This has been a remarkable conversation.
I think we could easily
go for another hour.
The audience has been
inspired by your comments,
and I think you've given
both a general framework
for thinking about where
we're falling short,
namely addressing equality and
also given us room for hope
that some of the victories
that have been one in the past
for standing up for economic justice
and standing up for those
who are adversely affected
by stigma and discrimination
that we can carry those forward
with new technologies and do better.
We thank you so much for joining us today,
and we'll be following your work closely
and we'll take forward your
words with inspiration.
- Well, thank you so much
and greetings to my brothers
and sisters in Uganda.
Thank you for being with you
and I enjoy engaging with
students and intellectuals.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.